Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui on va parler
du télescope spatial James Webb. Je suis
sûr que vous avez tous vu passer les magnifiques
images qui ont été révélées mi-juillet,
à l’issue des 6 premiers mois de fonctionnement
du télescope.
Mais outre les images, les équipes en charge
du télescope ont également publié un gros
article scientifique d’une cinquantaine
de pages afin de faire le bilan du fonctionnement
de la bête suite à cette période de mise
en service.
J’ai eu l’occasion de lire l’article
et aujourd’hui je vais donc vous raconter
le fonctionnement du télescope, et ce que
les scientifiques en disent à l’issue de
ce rodage. Et clairement ce qu’il en ressort,
c’est que pour l’instant le télescope
James Webb fonctionne quasi-parfaitement,
et dépasse même les attentes des scientifiques
sur ses performances.
Avant de rentrer dans le vif du sujet, essayons
déjà de comprendre quels sont les objectifs
scientifiques de ce télescope, dans quel
but a-t-il été conçu. Tout d’abord un
point clé, il s’agit d’un télescope
qui observe l’infrarouge.
[SPECTRE Vous savez sans doute que le spectre
des ondes électromagnétiques est composé
de différentes familles suivant la longueur
d’onde, ça va des rayons gamma aux ondes
radios en passant par le visible, l’infrarouge
ou encore les micro-ondes.
Et toutes ces longueurs d’ondes peuvent
être utilisées pour faire de l’astronomie,
pour regarder le ciel : on peut observer aussi
bien la lumière visible que les rayons X,
l’infrarouge ou les ondes radios. Simplement
on ne peut pas utiliser le même appareil
pour tout. Un télescope est conçu pour fonctionner
dans une certaine plage de longueurs d’onde.
Le télescope spatial Hubble fonctionne entre
200nm et 2.4 microns, c’est-à-dire l’UV,
le visible et le proche infrarouge. Le télescope
James Webb lui est conçu pour opérer entre
600 nm et 28 microns. 600 nm ça veut dire
qu’il voit le rouge et l’orange, mais
pas vraiment les autres couleurs visibles.
En particulier contrairement à Hubble, il
ne voit pas le bleu, ou encore moins les UV.]
[CARINA Donc quand vous voyez une image comme
celle-ci ça n’est pas littéralement ce
que voit le télescope. Ce sont des fausses
couleurs. En l’occurence ici le bleu représente
des longueurs d’onde autour de 900nm, c’est
du proche infra-rouge.]
Alors pourquoi observer l’infrarouge, c’est
quoi l’intérêt scientifique, pourquoi
ne pas avoir choisi la même plage que Hubble
par exemple. Eh bien il y a plusieurs objectifs.
Tout d’abord, observer des galaxies très
lointaines. Vous le savez peut-être, plus
une galaxie est lointaine, plus elle nous
apparait rouge, à cause de l’expansion
de l’Univers. Et en fait même carrément,
infrarouge.
Hubble était capable de voir des galaxies
datant d’enrivon 500 millions d’années
après le Big-Bang, et leurs longueurs d’ondes
étaient tellement décalées vers le rouge
qu’elles étaient multipliées par 10. On
appelle ce facteur le Redshift, souvent noté
z. Et Hubble a pu voir des galaxies jusque’à
z=11.
Le télescope James Webb, lui, devrait être
capable d’observer des décalages jusqu’à
z=20, pour des galaxies datant de seulement
150 millions d’années après le BigBang.
[DECALAGE SPECTRE Mais z=20, ça veut dire
la chose suivante. Prenez une étoile comme
le Soleil, qui émet tout un spectre de longueurs
d’onde dont le pic est autour de 500nm,
en plein dans la lumière visible donc. Eh
bien à z=20 une étoile comme le Soleil nous
apparaitrait décalée avec un pic à 10 microns.
Complètement dans l’infrarouge, et impossible
à observer en lumière visible.]
Evidemment à une telle distance on ne va
pas observer des étoiles individuelles mais
des galaxies entières, mais vous voyez l’idée
d’observer dans l’infrarouge. On pourra
mieux détecter ces galaxies lointaines et
très anciennes, et donc mieux comprendre
comme les premières galaxies se sont formées
après le Big Bang.
Autre intérêt de l’infrarouge, il traverse
beaucoup mieux les nuages de poussières.
Plus la longueur d’onde est grande, moins
la lumière est affectée par la diffusion
sur des petites particules. Ca se voit très
bien sur l’image que j’ai déjà montrée,
la Nébuleuse de la Carène, quand on compare
Hubble et le James Webb.
[HST/JWST Non seulement avec James Webb la
résolution est meilleure, mais en plus on
voit des choses qui se passent derrière,
en arrière plan, et qui avec Hubble n’étaient
pas détectées car la lumière visible est
plus facilement bloquée par la poussière.
En infrarouge, ça permet de voir à travers
les nuages de poussière, et donc d’avoir
accès à des phénomènes nouveaux, en particulier
concernant la naissance des étoiles et l’évolution
des galaxies.]
Et puis dernier intérêt de l’infra-rouge,
c’est d’observer des exoplanètes. Si
on prend une planète comme la Terre, elle
est à 15°C environ en moyenne.
[SPECTRE TERRE Donc son rayonnement naturel,
celui qu’on appelle le rayonnement de corps
noir, qui résulte de sa température, est
distribué autour de 10 microns. Donc l’infrarouge
est très adapté à la recherche d’exoplanètes
ayant une température proche de la nôtre.]
En particulier, pour espérer trouver des
traces de vie extraterrestre, on aimerait
pouvoir estimer la composition de certaines
planètes à partir des longueurs d’onde
absorbées par leur atmosphère dans l’infrarouge.
[TERRE Avec la plage d’observation du James
Webb, voici à quoi ressemblerait le spectre
en transmission de la Terre dans l’infrarouge.
Tous les creux correspondent à des longueurs
d’ondes absorbées par certaines molécules,
l’eau, le méthane, etc. et nous renseignent
donc sur la composition de l’atmosphère.]
Au total, pour tous ces différents objectifs
scientifiques, l’infrarouge c’est super.
La difficulté en temps normal, c’est que
comme on vient de le dire, l’atmosphère
de la Terre absorbe beaucoup d’infrarouges.
Donc c’est une plage de longueurs d’ondes
pas facile à observer avec un télescope
basé au sol; d’où l’intérêt d’aller
dans l’espace.
Voilà pour les objectifs scientifiques du
télescope, passons maintenant à la mission
elle-même. Vous vous en souvenez peut-être,
le lancement a eu lieu le 25 décembre 2021
depuis la base de Kourou en Guyane, à bord
d’une fusée Ariane 5.
Le lancement a été un très gros succès,
et ça n’est pas rien parce qu’on parle
quand même d’un bébé qui est développé
depuis plus de 20 ans, et qui aura coûté
10 milliards de dollars. Donc il y avait un
peu de pression au décollage.
Concernant la localisation du télescope,
il faut bien comprendre qu’on est sur quelque
chose de très très différent du télescope
Hubble. C’est même assez difficile de comparer
les échelles, même les schémas fournis
par la NASA sont faux, mais essayons quand
même.
[POSITION La Terre fait environ 12700 km de
diamètre. La station spatiale internationale
orbite à 400km d’altitude. Donc très proche
de la surface finalement. Hubble lui se trouve
à 540km d’altitude, un peu au-dessus.
La lune se trouve à 380 000 km, donc 700
fois plus loin que Hubble, il faut que je
dé-zoome, et on ne voit plus du tout l’orbite
du télescope Hubble. Et si je garde les tailles
à l’échelle on ne voit pas grand chose
alors je vais les agrandir.
Et le James Webb, eh bien il se trouve à
1,5 millions de kilomètres de la Terre, je
dois encore dézoomer. Et en fait il n’est
pas en orbite autour de la Terre, mais plutôt
du Soleil. Mais en un endroit très spécial
qu’on appelle le point de Lagrange L2.]
L’idée de ce point particulier de l’espace,
c’est de faire en sorte que le télescope
spatial tourne autour du Soleil, mais au même
rythme que la Terre, pour pas qu’il se trouve
d’un côté du Soleil quand nous on est
de l’autre.
Le souci c’est que normalement plus un objet
se trouve éloigné du Soleil, plus sa période
de révolution est lente.
[KEPLER Par exemple si on fait le tour en
un an, Vénus qui est plus proche fait le
tour du Soleil en seulement 8 mois, et Mars
plus lointaine en presque 2 ans. Donc si on
met le télescope quelque part entre la Terre
et Mars, il va tourner trop lentement pour
rester Synchro avec la Terre.
Sauf qu’il existe quelques points très
particuliers, qui sont tels que l’attraction
combinée de la Terre et du Soleil fait en
sorte que la période soit synchrone avec
celle de la Terre.
[LAGRANGE Ca s’appelle les points de Lagrange,
et il y en a un dans l’axe Soleil-Terre,
à 1.5 millions de kilomètres, c’est le
point dit «L2». Et c’est un endroit
de choix pour ce genre de satellite, on y
trouve aussi le satellite Planck lancé en
2009 qui a observé le rayonnement fossile.
Pour ceux que ça intéresse j’avais fait
un billet de blog il y a longtemps sur les
points de Lagrange, je vous mets le lien en
description.]
L’intérêt de ce point L2, c’est que
le télescope aura une position à peu près
constante par rapport à la Terre, la Lune
et le Soleil, ce qui évitera les changements
de température qui seraient compliqués à
gérer. Là le télescope aura toujours le
dos au Soleil mais ne sera jamais dans l’ombre.
[MODELE 3D J’ai téléchargé un modèle
3D du satellite, et on voit ici la partie
télescope proprement dite, et là un grand
bouclier thermique pour bloquer les rayons
du soleil qui arriveront comme ça. On a aussi
des panneaux solaires pour alimenter l’ensemble
avec une puissance proche de 2 kW.
Ca c’est pour la logistique, mais puisqu’on
est sur le modèle, passons maintenant au
coeur, la partie télescope proprement dite.
La caractéristique reconnaissable du James
Webb, c’est évidemment ce grand miroir
doré en nid d’abeille. Mais dans le dispositif,
il y a en réalité dans 3 miroirs consécutifs.
Ce design avec trois miroirs permet de minimiser
certaines aberrations optiques.
Le deuxième miroir beaucoup plus petit est
ici, il reçoit les rayons en provenance du
premier premier, et il est fixé sur cette
espèce de structure avec 3 pattes.
Et enfin le troisième miroir est là-dedans,
il reçoit la lumière renvoyée par le deuxième,
et la dirige vers les instruments de mesure.]
Le miroir principal fait 6m50 de diamètre,
ça fait une surface environ 4 fois plus importante
que le télescope Hubble. Et ce qui est notable,
c’est son allure particulière. La raison,
c’est que lancer directement un miroir de
plus de 6m, ça aurait été compliqué, d’où
le fait d’utiliser ces 18 miroirs hexagonaux,
qui se sont dépliés une fois le télescope
en place.
Ces miroirs sont recouvert d’une fine couche
d’or, c’est pour bien réfléchir les
rayonnements infrarouges qui nous intéressent,
et chacun est monté sur une série de micromoteurs
qui peuvent permettre de donner à l’ensemble
du miroir la forme adéquate.
La précision de ces micromoteurs serait inférieure
à 100nm. Ca veut dire qu’on arrive modifier
la forme d’un truc qui fait 6m à l’échelle
de 100nm, un dix-millième de millimètre.
C’est dingue.
Dans la phase de mise en service qui vient
de s’achever, les responsables du télescope
ont voulu évidemment tester pour voir s’il
répondait bien au cahier des charges. Est-ce
que du point de vue de l’optique, on atteint
les résolutions voulues.
Pour ça, on doit notamment mesurer une quantité
qu’on appelle la PSF, Point Spread Fonction.
[DIFFRACTION L’idée c’est qu’avec un
télescope, même si vous observez une source
super ponctuelle, un point minuscule dans
le ciel, il ne fera jamais pile un point sur
les images que vous récupérez. Ca va toujours
baver un peu, faire une sorte de tâche, notamment
à cause du phénomène diffraction.
La diffraction limite fondamentalement la
résolution, et la PSF c’est en gros à
quoi va ressembler sur l’image un truc qui
aurait du être un point. Dans quelle mesure
ça bave.]
[PSF Avec le James Webb la PSF a une forme
un peu particulière, ça n’est pas juste
une tâche ronde, mais on voit comme des pics
à des angles de 60°.
C’est parfaitement normal, on sait que ces
pics sont dus aux raccords entre les hexagones
du miroir primaire, et à la structure qui
tient le miroir secondaire. Ils apparaissent
surtout quand on a une source très lumineuse,
comme sur cette image. Mais en contrepartie
on sait que la tâche central sera moins étalée,
donc c’était un choix assumé dans le design
du télescope.
[RMS WFE La façon dont tout ça s’étale
peut se quantifier, il y a un indicateur et
plus c’est faible, mieux c’est. Et je
vous passe les détails techniques, mais ce
qu’on voit sur ce graphique tiré de l’article,
c’est qu’à chaque fois les performances
réelles sont meilleures que ce qui avait
été anticipé. Donc gros succès de ce point
de vue là.]
Bien, maintenant qu’on sait que les miroirs
marchent bien, passons aux instruments que
l’on met derrière pour obtenir des images.
On l’a dit l’idée est d’observer dans
l’infrarouge, de 600nm jusque’à 28 microns.
Et pour faire ça, on va utiliser différents
types de capteurs.
Un premier instrument accessoire mais important,
c’est le FGS, Fine Guidance System. C’est
un instrument qui sert juste au satellite
à repérer les étoiles environnantes pour
pouvoir se positionner précisément. C’est
un peu son GPS si vous voulez.
[FGS Et ce qui est fou, c’est que rien que
les images faites avec sont déjà super chouettes.
Pour un truc qui n’est pas censé servir
à prendre des photos, il marche quand même
vachement bien. Et par ailleurs son efficacité
pour le positionnement est excellente.]
Petite anecdote, pour se repérer le FGS utilise
un catalogue d’étoiles, dont les positions
sont connues. Et apparemment parfois en utilisant
ces étoiles pour positionner le satellite,
le FGS a découvert que certaines de ces «étoiles»
du catalogue étaient en fait des galaxies
(page 10). Oups.
Passons maintenant aux instruments principaux.
Pour faciliter les choses, ils sont divisés
en deux plages d’observations.
[SPECTRE Entre 0.6 et 5 microns, le proche
infrarouge, et entre 5 et 27 microns, plutôt
l’infrarouge moyen. Pour l’infrarouge
proche, il y a l’instrument NIRCam, pour
Near Infrared Camera.
Il couvre un champ angulaire de 2 arc minutes,
c’est 1/30°de degré. Donc imaginez un
fenêtre d’1 millimètre-carré située
à deux mètres de vous. Et pour faire une
photo de ce minuscule bout de ciel, on a 10
capteurs de 4 mégapixels.
Et toutes les longueurs d’onde ne sont pas
observées de la même façon, on utilise
différent filtres qui balayent la plage.
Et à partir de ce qu’on observe avec chaque
filtre, on peut faire des rendus en fausses
couleurs comme celui dont on a parlé au début.
Un point important de ces appareils, c’est
que pour observer correctement le ciel dans
cette gamme de longueurs d’onde, il ne faut
pas que l’instrument lui-même soit trop
chaud. Sinon son propre rayonnement thermique
va venir perturber la mesure.
Pour ça, la température du capteur doit
être rester en-dessous de 37 Kelvins, donc
pas loin de -235°C. Et avec ça, acquérir
une image va quand même prendre plusieurs
heures. Donc le télescope doit bien sûr
se maintenir dans la bonne orientation pour
compenser sa trajectoire.
L’instrument NIRCam permet donc de faire
des images, très résolues. Mais on n’a
des infos que sur les bandes de longueurs
d’onde qui ont été choisies en fonction
des filtres. Une chose très intéressante
qu’on fait aussi en astronomie, c’est
de la spectroscopie, c’est à dire mesurer
avec précision la composition du spectre
sur toute une plage de longueur d’onde.
J’en avais parlé dans ma vidéo sur les
exoplanètes, pour faire ça on utilise un
spectrographe. Et souvent c’est un appareil
d’analyse qu’on met derrière le télescope,
pour analyser la lumière de l’ensemble
de l’image. Donc par exemple on pointe sur
une étoile et on analyse cette étoile.
Le problème c’est qu’avec le télescope
James Webb, on peut avoir potentiellement
tout un tas d’objets intéressants, et qui
sont différents donc on ne veut pas les analyser
ensemble. Or il se trouve que l’instrument
NIRSpec permet de faire de la Spector multiobjets.
[NIRSpec On peut sélectionner les objets
d’intérêt sur une image, et grâce à
un système de masques et de micro obturateurs,
NIRSPec analysera individuellement les spectres
des différents objets. Balèze.]
Tout ça c’était pour la gamme 0.6 à 5
microns. Passons maintenant au-delà de 5
microns, et jusqu’à 27 microns. Et là
c’est encore plus compliqué. Si c’est
de l’infrarouge plus lointain, ça veut
dire qu’il faut refroidir encore plus bas
pour éviter les parasites thermiques.
Grâce à un circuit à hélium liquide recyclé,
l’instrument MIRI est refroidit à 6 Kelvins
seulement, -267 °C. Et c’est un instrument
qui va faire à la fois Caméra, pour faire
des images, et Spectro pour avoir les spectres.
[SPECTRE ET INSTRUMENTS Pour être complets,
ajoutons aussi l’instrument NIRISS, qui
est couplé au système de positionnement
FGS, et qui permet aussi de faire des spectres
mais sur des grands angles de vue. Enfin grand,
1/30° de degré quoi.
Et dernière précision, il y a tous ces instruments
à bord, et quand on observe il faut choisir
lequel on utilise, mais apparemment il existe
plusieurs manières d’en utiliser deux à
la fois, ça peut servir.]
Ca c’était pour la partie vraiment acquisition
du signal. Mais maintenant il faut transmettre
tout ça vers la Terre. On ne fait sur place
qu’un minimum de traitements. Il y a un
convertisseur Analogique Numérique qui consomme
seulement 11mW, pour éviter de chauffer comme
une carte graphique et de perturber les mesures.
Et ensuite tout est transmis vers la Terre
avec un débit de 28 Mégabits par seconde,
donc c’est pas tout à fait la fibre.
Alors à nouveau, qu’est-ce qu’on apprend
dans le rapport sur le fonctionnement de tous
ces instruments. Eh bien ça marche nickel.
Tous les instruments marchent mieux que prévu
avec des sensibilités souvent meilleures
que les spécifications visées. Champagne
!
Maintenant c’est quoi l’avenir du télescope.
Eh bien il faut quand même parler des deux
trucs qui sont des défauts, et qui sont discutés
dans le rapport. Premièrement, il existe
dans le satellite un chemin lumineux appelé
«voyou», qui permet à de la lumière
parasite d’atteindre directement le troisième
miroir sans passer par les deux autres.
[ROGUE C’était anticipé, et ça provoque
dans certaines circonstances des défauts
sur les images, qui portent des noms poétiques
comme les griffes, ou le sabre laser. A priori
rien de trop grave, en tout cas c’était
prévu que ça arrive.]
Deuxième souci moins bénin, le télescope
se prend des micrométéorites. Les micrométéorites
c’est moins d’un gramme normalement, et
là aussi c’était prévu. Il avait été
calculé que le miroir devait s’en prendre
en moyenne une par mois, mais sans gravité
à part la nécessité de rebouger un peu
le miroir touché.
Et effectivement c’est qu’il s’est passé,
il y a eu en 6 mois 5 impacts de micrométéorites.
Mais un de ceux-là, a été beaucoup plus
sérieux que prévu. Au point qu’il a légèrement
dégradé les performances optiques du télescope.
[PSF Je vous remontre le graphique que je
vous avais affiché pour dire que les performances
étaient meilleures que prévues. Plus c’est
bas, mieux c’est, et les parties plus claires
en bleu et vert, c’est la performance qui
a été irrémédiablement perdue à cause
du choc de cette micrométéorite.]
A ce stade on ne sait pas si c’est juste
un coup de malchance, mais il faudra pas que
ça se reproduise trop souvent. Donc petite
inquiétude de ce côté là. D’autant que
le télescope est à 1.5 millions de kilomètres
donc faire une maintenance c’est hors de
question.
Dans le cas de Hubble, il y a eu 4 missions
de maintenance qui ont permis de prolonger
beaucoup sa durée de vie, mais là on était
à 500km de la Terre, pas 1.5 millions de
kilomètres. Donc là le James Webb, si on
le perd, on le perd.
A part ça, les perspectives sont excellentes,
notamment concernant la longévité du télescope.
Il est alimenté par panneaux solaires, donc
pas de limite de batterie. Et contrairement
à d’autres satellites, le système de refroidissement
est en circuit fermé. Donc on n’épuise
pas le fluide réfrigérant.
A priori le principal facteur limitant, c’est
le combustible. Alors il l’utilise très
peu puisqu’il est sur une orbite, mais il
faut quand même remettre les gaz environ
10 secondes toutes les 3 semaines, pour assurer
la stabilité de la trajectoire et compenser
le fait que les photons du soleil le poussent
en tapant sur le bouclier thermique.
Le télescope James Webb a décollé avec
200 L de combustible, ce qui était censé
lui permettre de se positionner correctement,
puis de tenir entre 5 et 10 ans en fonctionnement.
Mais le lancement a été tellement bon et
précis, qu’il n’a presque pas tapé dans
les réserves, et il devrait tenir au moins
20 ans.
Alors comment ça se passe maintenant que
la mise en service est terminée. Eh bien
les astronomes du monde entier peuvent soumettre
des propositions pour obtenir du temps d’observation
sur le télescope. Il y aura un appel chaque
année pour attribuer les créneaux de l’année
suivante, et un comité scientifique qui tranchera.
Pour le premier cycle d’observation qui
commence, près de 1200 projets ont été
soumis, et seulement 266 retenus pour se partager
environ 6000 heures d’observation. Si ça
vous amuse en théorie n’importe qui peut
soumettre un projet, il y a même la documentation
du télescope en ligne. Mais à votre place
j’essayerai pas.
Voilà c’est tout pour ce tour d’horizon
du James Webb, qui est quand même une sacré
aventure scientifique et technologique, et
qui pour l’instant se présente plutôt
sous les meilleures auspices.
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo, si ça vous
intéresse je mettrai le lien de l’article
scientifique qui est assez lisible. Abonnnez
vous, activez la cloche pour ne rien rater,
et on se retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
vidéo. A bientôt.